what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we have a little bit of a shift in
some of the movies coming out don't
worry nothing huge but disney did
release an updated release schedule for
all of their movies coming out all the
way out till 2025 and on this updated
release schedule from 2022 to 2025 we
have 11 marvel movies listed that's a
lot of movies coming within just three
years now there's a lot of movies that
of course we know about on here but
there are some mystery movies listed
here that we don't actually know what
movie is going to fall in the slot that
is listed we have the year and we have
the exact date but the movie remains a
mystery however of course we believe
that these slots are reserved for movies
such as the fantastic four deadpool 3
and hopefully an x-men or mutant movie
especially after patrick stewart's
professor xavier has been teased in
multiverse of madness so i'm going to go
over this entire new slate talk about
each of the marvel slots coming up what
movies go into the slots and these
mystery titles as well what the movies
could be and of course if you're new and
you love marvel be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
videos now from the most part from 2022
where we are right now to the end of
2023 we know what marvel has in store
for us there are a few very minor
changes to some of the upcoming release
dates that we'll talk about but only a
couple so let's get that out of the way
and talk about some upcoming movies that
we are really excited for that disney
has now given exact release dates for we
also have a minor deadpool 3 update and
a thor love and thunder trailer update
which we'll talk about as well now right
now as this slate states it has doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
coming out may 6th of 2022 now
originally it was scheduled for may 4th
so only a two day difference not that
big of a deal but it looks like they
wanted it to come out on a friday
instead of on a wednesday which makes
sense this way people will actually go
and see it thursday and that will start
its opening weekend off on may 6th which
is the friday so really minor change
doesn't really affect us fans but it
does affect the box office which of
course affects disney and marvel studios
now the next movie listed for 2022 is
thor love and thunder and that hasn't
changed it is still scheduled to come
out on july 8th of 2022
and while we're on the topic of thor
love and thunder rumor has it that we
could not confirm but we could be
getting a trailer next week the first
week of march now these are just rumors
going around but we are due for the
trailer mathematically speaking if we
look at the release dates for all of the
other trailers compared to when the
movies actually come out we are due for
the trailer and some people like grace
randolph have reported that they have
been hearing the same rumors that the
trailer could be coming next week so
fingers crossed if not it should be
coming within the next few weeks so keep
an eye out and of course i'll do an
update if i hear anything so no change
for thor love and thunder and the next
movie coming out in 2022 is black
panther 2 wakanda forever and that is
still scheduled for november 11th so no
change there which is really good
because fans are really anticipating
black panther 2. we don't really know
what to expect they're not recasting
t'challa and we don't know who the new
black panther is going to be or even if
there is going to be a new black panther
so hopefully there are no more delays
and that does come at the end of this
year so that's three movies for 2022 now
keep in mind we're not doing disney plus
shows right now we are just focusing on
the movies because that is all that was
released in the schedule but moving on
to 2023 we actually get four marvel
movies that's a lot of movies in one
year especially if you consider we're
probably going to be getting at least
three probably four marvel disney plush
shows at the same time so disney and
marvel are certainly busy especially if
you actually consider disney is probably
going to have other star wars disney
plus shows come out as well so very busy
time but the first marvel movie coming
out in 2020 is the marvels or captain
marvel 2. that is scheduled for february
17th of 2023 basically a year from now
and of course it's called the marvels
because there's actually going to be
three marvels in this movie of course we
have captain marvel we have miss marvel
which of course is also a disney plus
show coming very soon and then we'll
have tayonna paris's monica rambo and
we're not really sure what she's going
to be called at this point she's been
called photon pulsar and spectrum in the
comics but this movie will feature these
three awesome and powerful ladies going
to work now the next movie coming out
not too long after in 2023 is guardians
of the galaxy vol 3. this actually got
moved up a little bit it was originally
scheduled for may 23rd of 2023 but is
now scheduled for may 5th so it's been
moved up 18 days and everybody is really
looking forward to this one as it's
going to introduce adam warlock to the
mcu and from what we know and believe
right now the high evolutionary will
also be introduced as the main villain
and not to mention there are going to be
some deaths happening in guardians 3 so
everybody's really anticipating this one
now following guardians 3 is ant-man and
the wasp quantum mania where we will see
the introduction of kang this is
currently listed for july 28th of 2023
so nothing has changed here but here's
where things actually get really
interesting listed for november 3rd of
2023 it states that there is an untitled
marvel movie that would be the fourth
movie of 2023 following the marvels
guardians 3 and ant-man and the was
quantomania making for a heck of a year
especially if you consider what movies
we know are coming out that don't have
confirmed release dates for and this
goes for the other slots as well which
i'll go over and then we'll talk about
what movies they could be the other
slots for 2024 are february 16th again
it just states untitled marvel movie and
then another untitled marvel film on may
3rd then we have another untitled marvel
film july 26th and then the final one on
november 8th so four movies again in
2024 and for the star wars fans there's
an untitled star wars film scheduled for
december 19th of 2025. now what could
these untitled marvel films be it's
really exciting if you think about the
movies that have been confirmed first
off let's talk about deadpool 3 because
ryan reynolds recently said that he's
going to have an update on deadpool 3
really soon he actually said sooner
rather than later now ryan reynolds has
denied that deadpool is going to be in
multiverse of madness but everybody has
to deny i mean patrick stewart recently
just said who is dr strange when we know
he knows who he is so if deadpool gets
introduced into the mcu in the upcoming
months here deadpool 3 is probably right
around the corner even if he doesn't get
introduced in multiverse of madness we
know that deadpool 3 is coming very soon
so deadpool 3 could very well be in 2023
or it could be one of these 2024 slots
then of course we have blade that movie
has been confirmed and we actually did
hear mahershala ali's blade in the
post-credits scene for the eternals
talking to the black knight so he's kind
of been introduced into the mcu already
and they clearly have plans for him soon
so he could very well take this 2023
slot but if not i'm definitely seeing
blade in one of these 2024 slots for
sure now in the last update that we got
from kevin feige about the fantastic
four he actually said that it has begun
it's in production so i am definitely
thinking that the fantastic four is one
of these 2024 untitled marvel film slots
which is really really exciting because
that means we only have a couple of
years to wait until marvel's first
family finally makes it to the mcu which
means we only have about a year until
everything is revealed as far as the
cast is concerned and of course we can't
talk about the fantastic four without
talking about mutants
the x-men at san diego comic-con in 2019
kevin feige did confirm the x-men and
the fantastic four were being worked on
and are coming to the mcu soon and since
we are getting patrick stewart's
professor xavier in multiverse of
madness and the x-men are appearing in
the mcu i am assuming that an actual
x-men or mutants film is in the works
right now and will be hitting the
theaters relatively soon within the next
handful of years so an x-men or mutant
film could very well be one of these
untitled slots for 2024 and then of
course spider-man 4 has been confirmed
with tom holland marvel studios
president kevin feige confirmed this
with executive producer over at sony amy
pascal now if they put this at the end
of 2024 that will basically be three
years from spider-man no way home which
is plenty of time in between films so
there's a very good chance that
spider-man 4 could be coming in
2024. now there are two final movies
that have been confirmed but haven't
really been talked about much and that
is captain america 4 and shangchi 2. now
either of these movies could hold one of
these 20 24 release dates i definitely
don't think they're going to get that
2023 slot but i definitely think they
are going to be coming soon however i
don't think they'll probably have the
2024 slots either maybe one of them but
since we haven't really heard anything
besides the fact that they are happening
i'm gonna say they're probably coming in
2025 or later but regardless we have
these release dates and pretty soon
marvel will reveal which movies are
going to be coming and if we think about
these movies that i just listed that we
know are confirmed it's really exciting
fantastic four deadpool 3 x-men blade
and a ton of other movies it's super
exciting the future is really really
bright for marvel studios so be sure to
let me know which one you are most
excited about in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news for live updates you
can always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof